bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors le gouvernement semble
vouloir muscler sa communication avec le
retour du point presse hebdomadaire
d'olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé quel est l'objectif rendre plus
audible la parole du gouvernement
bonjour doha oui effectivement on peut
imaginer que si le maquereau a demandé à
olivier ferrand un point hebdomadaire
certainement pour occuper l'espace un
tout simplement et reprendre la main sur
la parole pour être les seuls
pourvoyeurs de vérité autour de cette
crise qu vide mais en réalité il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui nous rentrons dans
une nouvelle phase de communication de
la part du gouvernement qui n'a plus
grand chose à voir avec le co vide c'est
qu'on en train de préparer la campagne
2022 donc il faut occuper le terrain un
style les éléments parce que ce point de
devenir donne l'idée un peu d'urgence et
de préoccupations principales du
gouvernement autour de la question
alors qu'en fait les déplacements de
jean castex le dernier mois où les
dernières sorties de notre président
n'ont rien à voir avec la avec la crise
du co lead donc on voit bien qu'en fait
c'est possible c'est une bonne aubaine
locaux vides aujourd'hui pour emmanuel
macron et que là le gouvernement est en
ordre de marche pour la campagne 2022 et
pour aucun autre objectif et
communication qui est jugé beaucoup trop
anxiogène par certains médecins
est ce que vous voulez rejoignez sur cet
avis mais quand on décortique tacle une
question du gouvernement aujourd'hui
c'était par emmanuel macron elle
correspond à résoudre aujourd'hui son
problème principal qui est la reprise la
contestation sociale dans la rue donc il
faut construire tous les éléments de
culpabilisation pour pouvoir prendre les
mesures qui vont empêcher les
rassemblements de personnes et
sanctionner encore plus durement les
gens qui oserait marcher dans la rue
pour dire qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord
avec sa politique
donc effectivement il si vous commencez
à préparer un tel pas un tapis anxieuse
rien on entend la communication c'est
beaucoup plus simple ensuite de
légitimer les mesures qui vont être
prises
et ces mesures ont pour principal
objectif aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec eux
des gens qui sont aujourd'hui
verbalisées ou arrêtés dans la rue parce
qu'ils ont un tract dans la poche
ça n'a rien à voir qu'ils ont un masque
qui sont à distance d'un mètre et qu'ils
ont du gène dans le clic sur eux donc
qui n'a rien à voir avec la possible
contamination des gens autour d'eux mais
bien sûr le fait de contester dans la
rue donc de faire ce 7,7 le débat après
moi je suis
médecin donc je peux pas savoir si c'est
réaliste ou pas le scénario qui nous est
aujourd'hui proposée en tout cas suggéré
par le gouvernement mais bon sang des
médecins la part pour le coup ce sont
leur boulot on peut peut-être leur faire
confiance
mais ce qui est certain c'est que oui en
tout cas on en train de faire peur il se
retourne en train de culpabiliser la
population pour pour le cas où on
appliquerait pas ce que le gouvernement
va commencer à nous annoncer ou les
préfectures d'ailleurs en ce qu'il est
possible que ça passe plutôt par les
préfets pour pouvoir à nouveau se
dédouaner les menus leurs prises et
bourque emmanuel macron ne soit pas le
président de la répression
ce qu'il est enfin c'est le président
d'un crime aux jeunes depuis départ il
fait il nous fait pleurer
que ce soit dans la rue ou par les
mesures qu'il prend donc donc oui c'est
en termes de stratégie de communication
de faire peur d'abord permettre
justifier ensuite ce qui est des mesures
qui ont été annoncées
alors le gouvernement doit répondre non
seulement aux rebonds de la pandémie
mais également surmonter la méfiance
croissante de la population sait que
près d'un français sur deux trouve que
l'exécutif ne prend pas assez de
précautions 62% ne lui font pas
confiance pour lutter contre l'épidémie
comment justement regagner la confiance
des français
force a pour le coup je retournerai pas
à voir ce talent là parce que cette
confiance est brisée de plus plusieurs
façons dans un livre là qui va sortir
qui est assez intéressant sur l'une des
plumes des manuels mâcon pendant la
campagne qui explique à quel point il a
menti dans tous ses discours et qu'il le
savait donc le mensonge permanent brise
la confiance ça je vais évidemment rien
vous apprendre en faisant ça sera donc
donc pour reconstruire la confiance
aujourd'hui alors que l'épisode des
masques il en fallait pas puis l'info
enfin on a eu c'est eux cette espèce de
communication absolument guignolesque
depuis six mois rappelez vous des points
presse de cible et n'diaye pendant la
crise ducobu id rappelez-vous des trois
grands live edu d'emmanuel macron où il
a raconté absolument tout et n'importe
quoi
et puis depuis le début de son
quinquennat macron emmanuel macron ment
en permanence et son gouvernement aussi
donc là de retrouver la confiance il va
faire commencer par faire ce qu'il a
annoncé qu'il allait faire notamment
pendant la campagne dans ce cas là et
j'avais dire remettre de l'ordre et akon
kid incapable de faire ne pas supprimer
liezel donc de rétablir ne va pas tout
ce qu'il avait promis de faire donc
c'est une accumulation de petites
trahisons de futilité au retour sur sa
parole parce qu'à force de dire en même
temps tout et son contraire ces lieux en
même temps des manuels mâcon eh bien on
raconte à peu près rien et surtout
n'importe quoi et on sera pas leur a
multiplié les discours il se fait tout
le monde plus discret sur la question du
coronavirus il prépare justement la
future campagne présidentielle
mais là ils la préparent totalement on
est en pleine crise du coc vide quels
sont les sorties des manuels macro on à
gala donc organisé par évidemment parole
mme marchand qui le positionne en
seconde soit 160 scooter des mers en
pleine crise du coc vide
pourquoi est-ce que même la comelle
macron c'est ça qu'elle est le seul
intérêt c'est de se positionner en homme
fort évidemment et c'est super gentil de
culture viriliste dont il ne se sent
absolument pas et envoie là toute la
dimension de mépris du personnage à une
censure à la réalité de notre pays
aujourd'hui voire même de notre société
un plus globalement aujourd'hui sur le
rapport à la virilité mais ça le seul
intérêt c'est 2022 aucun intérêt de
sortir cette 7 e 7 e cet article avec
lui comparé à jean donc sur un scooter
des mers en pleine crise
aucun à part préparé 2022 jean castex
qu'on appelle dans les couloirs des
ministères
la suspicion référence au dîner de cons
de serres castet a également puisque
noir philippe pétain plan encombrants
ils étaient comme à ces républicains
donc on a un nouveau premier ministre de
droite mais qui est totalement dévoué
fait et cause et même le maquereau en
tout cas qui transparente
donc effectivement toutes les actions
aujourd'hui toutes les puits toute la
musique de communication qui se met en
place n'a qu'un seul objectif c'est 2022
voire même les échéances électorales un
petit peu avant même si sur les
régionales je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de battre et que la machine est
en marche peu à peu comme elle l'a été
avant pour les municipales et ouidah
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron se lève le
matin non pas en pensant accrue du bon
rythme et à 2022 c'est une évidence une
évidence
merci
ou ludovic de l'air d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en communication